[Musique]
pour terminer ce journal nous allons
vous présenter un moyen tout à fait
originale pour protéger vos trésors si
vous en avez du moins moins coûteux que
les portes blindées ou que les vigiles
ce système est très économique
il consomme juste un peu d'alcool je
vous le laisse découvrir tout de suite
[Musique]
par un beau dimanche après midi je me
suis promené à la malade près de
besançon
le soleil brillait et les fleurs
ressembler à de jolis papillons de
gentils oiseaux entonnait leurs plus
beaux chants je me suis approché d'une
ravissante mais honnête qui semblait
sortir d'un conte de fées
[Musique]
elle est très familier puis en même
temps il est quand même méchant pour les
chats bassecourt qua non titi h deux ans
profession proxénète
ben tu étais macro et 12 poules c'est
normal l'histoire de ce coq va sans
doute faire pleurer dans les poulaillers
kitty premier avant de devenir le roi de
la basse cour a connu la misère
abandonné à la naissance il a été
recueilli par monsieur barbier et c'est
par reconnaissance qu'il protège
aujourd'hui sa maison férocement et
s'attaque aux féroces d'accord mais
enfin quand même pas quand même pas
bouffer les gens il s'est jamais attaqué
à quelqu'un c'est moi on connaît très
bien ça va mais c'est quelqu'un qui
connaît pas alors là c'est autre chose
c'est autre chose
elle est là pour l'instant est gentil
comme tout près de moi vous pensez que
vous avez remis cette pancarte à votre
porte
un effet dissuasif sur des voleurs par
exemple ben si c'est possible surtout
les surtout la jeunesse ou les trucs
comme ça quoi
parce que vraiment même la jeunesse ou
une personne âgée en adoptant ce trait
dessus et puis je crois qu'ils partagent
le même goût que vous pour la bière à
moitié de sa petite bière soit à leurs
motifs oui bah il aime bien imputabilité
comme ça pas habitué enfin vouloir
donner souvent non plus maintenant c'est
fait il est ce vrai et c'est vrai
willem bien je crois qu'il va créer de
vieillesse certainement il finira pas
moi d'ailleurs suivre comme sont un
prétendant mais pas question
[Musique]